alors revenons à ce que vous racontez
simplement d'abord la jeunesse
d'isabelle et d'armement où elle va elle
passe je veux dire l vassal j'ai réalisé
alors il faut dire qu'elle est née à
genève de parents russes mais première
transgression c'est une enfant
illégitime
oui absolument je pense qu'il y avait
une raison à cela c'est que étant donné
que sa mère vivait sur des décret dit
qu'on lui envoyait de russie si cette
grande dame russe avait annoncé vraiment
officiellement qu'elle vivait avec le
précepteur de ses enfants et qu'elle en
avait un enfant je pense que on aurait
coupé on aurait coupé les crédits
première difficulté deuxième le
précepteur personnage colossal vava qui
est donc un tolstoï ac est un homme
forte instruit mais qui a oublié en
russie une femme et deux enfants et on
imagine que s'il avait reconnu sa fille
il y aurait eu immédiatement son
passeport enlever la bâtardise en russie
était considéré comme enfin il fit
bâtarde était très très mal traités il
ya des maliens et la mère la mère et
l'épousé d'un général elle et elle était
veuve d'un général quand enfin elle
avait une tradition aristocratique très
fort oui donc alors elle mais là à
genève et dans ce conte à vous appelle à
la villa neuve et tout ce qui se passe
cette villa neuve est assez très
romanesque parce que tous ces gens là
qui sont des immigrés sont filés par la
police suisse ya une raison à cela qui
est aussi que tous chacun comprendra
aujourd'hui c'est que cette ville très
pacifique qu'était genève l'encrier
n'est ce pas de tous les écrivains qui
allait là bas chercher la paix était
brusquement devenu dans les années 1870
7 jusqu'en 19 cents et est devenu une
plateforme internationale du terrorisme
chaque étudiant était suspect parce que
ils étaient russes et que et en russe
il était peut-être ni milice est ce que
j'ai voulu montrer c'est justement quels
sont les inconvénients pour une jeune
fille aventureuse de 14 15 ans de savoir
que partout où elle va
quand elle va acheter un livre quand
elle va acheter une veste les filets par
la police et le processus est un ferme
deux suspectes elle devient
instantanément réprouvé oui mais c'est
grâce à tous ces policiers qui ont fait
des fiches sur toute la famille vous
avez vu écrire le livre vous êtes allé
consulter toutes les fiches des agr et
voilà willy boly d'ailleurs il me semble
que vous avez fait ce travail de
policier vous et allez donc sur l'île
consultez toutes les crises de police au
moment où d'ailleurs gaston defferre et
l umih ministre de l'intérieur en france
oui mais j'ai choisi ce moment là parce
que je pensais que si j'avais vraiment
une enquête policière à faire eh bien je
serai aux premières loges
et c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai eu quelques
facilités mais le système policier était
fantastique car il est d'un modernisme
formidable aussi de crainte que les
terroristes en puissance qui étaient ces
étudiants anaïs et vire en france dès
qu'une fiche était fait
en suisse on la transmettait à la police
française c'était un espèce d'interpol
qui existait déjà
alors vous